president biden facing a nightmare come
christmas time thanks to rising
inflation and a supply crisis gifts are
going to cost you a fortune and that's
even if you're lucky enough to snag
anything thanks to massive delays
rocking the supply chain store shelves
are looking pretty empty as u.s ports
struggle to unload deliveries and get
this major retailers are actually being
forced to charter their own ships
and on top all of that biden's massive
spending plans are set to make things a
hundred times worse he said to address
the supply crisis tomorrow he says and
jenn saki was pressed on why the
president isn't being more forceful with
the unions to loosen work restrictions
that would ease the flow of goods we
have taken steps at times when warranted
to
loosen restrictions as you as you saw in
reaction to some natural disasters we've
had over the course of the year
ultimately the president's focus is
addressing the needs the challenges and
the threats to the american people of to
their well-being to their economic
well-being
and he'll consider a range of options
but again the supply chain task force
has been working for months to address
these issues task force and where is
transportation secretary pete boudej he
hasn't been to a white house briefing
since this whole crisis started
and when he manages to get in front of a
camera he doesn't say much we do believe
there's a role for
the federal government to play to help
smooth out some of these supply chain
issues it's largely a private sector
system we are funding of course as a
department a lot of work on the rails
on the roads and supporting trucking no
which is also a big issue we've got some
real challenges on the labor side with
the turnover of truck drivers
that can make it harder to get goods to
where they need to go some of this is is
a bigger picture longer term issue
that's going to take years and years to
address
years and years to address dana
uh kind of a laid-back attitude from the
administration is there like no urgency
for anything like why we just feel so
much urgency
during the campaign for president during
the primary campaign
joe biden said about mayor pete that
he's so inexperienced that while joe
biden's been in washington all this time
he's only been putting twinkly lights
under a bridge i mean that was how
insulting he was to him and now you have
somebody who was literally in charge of
the ports and the airlines and he's like
yeah i'm hanging out with aoc at the dog
park yesterday he tweeted about
indigenous people's day and you think
again i mentioned this yesterday about
kamala harris like you are in these
positions of power you have a you're in
a position to do something or at least
let people know we care because nothing
says return to normal like a shortage of
toilet paper which is what we're about
to see and we are getting into this
crisis of confidence danger zone when
little jesse junior can't get his
christmas presents that's going to be
bad oh no that will be bad and he will
not be happy about it however i think
there's another thing here it's not
beyond people not getting christmas
presents think of all the companies and
the people who do seasonal holiday work
right where they're helping ship things
out and get things on the stores all
those companies that hire people for the
holidays there'll be no need to do that
what's the ripple effect you're an elf
at the mall i know you and i have so
much fun
santa's always drunk and we do it for
free
all right greg uh what was it two months
ago joe biden came out and said our
experts believe this is a quote that
these bottlenecks and price spikes will
reduce as our company continues to heal
that was two months ago first i got to
point out that the best part about the
story is that there's a backlog of
toilet paper the worst thing to have
when there's no tp is a backlog
so yeah um
thank you that's about the best joke
he's told this season really
[Laughter]
so what we're seeing right now is we're
combining inflation with scarcity this
is a new thing so we're finally getting
the dystopia that the media said trump
was going to bring us except it's old
joe who's bringing us soylent green and
and bringing us to the thunder dome that
trump didn't i think our political
leaders uh while you're not sensing the
urgencies don't mind these problems they
don't mind that you pay more for gas
because that's you drive less right and
the fact that you have less money in the
bank means you have to rely on them so
it becomes more of a government state so
there's no urgency their kids are going
to get the gifts that your kids aren't
going to get because that's why they're
in politics to be exempt from the
scarcity that we have to deal with
remember the politicians in power did
nothing about crime because it didn't
affect them and they still haven't they
preached total lockdowns because they
were exempt from the total lockdowns we
need to abandon the idea that these
people in power actually give a damn
about us the only way you're going to
get any urgency at them is if they get
scared
to greg's point yes they're not going to
be affected by
the rise in prices degan but it's also a
pr thing for them they don't want to
appear
that anything is a crisis they want to
appear that they have everything under
control this is just a smooth recovery
and that's not sitting well with the
american people who are actually
affected by this right they're trying to
remain calm instead they come across as
uncaring asses right
this is what happens when people in
power
act according to their ideology and
don't act according to basic economic
fundamentals everything described here
in terms of the supply chain problems
the labor shortages the spike in
inflation
is a self-inflicted wound by the biden
administration it's intentional and even
if it wasn't
like directly related to some of the
recovery from the pandemic it is
certainly exacerbating all the troubles
one you don't pay people to stay at home
so you have the labor shortage 10 almost
10 and a half million jobs still open
there are three million people who have
completely left the labor force but then
you pay at pay people extra say
unemployment that started earlier this
year it just expired but you don't juice
demand while supplies are tight and this
task force they're talking about is
because that creates inflation this task
force is ludicrous because we've known
since at least beginning of this year
that the ships coming in were going to
be a huge headache that's when the big
retailer started worrying about it in
terms of energy prices this again is
intentional you cancel the keystone xl
pipeline you cancel all new permits for
drilling on federal land and then you in
a crisis beg opec
to pump more which does nothing to fight
global warming and you know who gets
screwed in all of this the small
businesses they don't have inventory and
they're they have nothing to sell to
raise revenue they can't even pay a
woman burst into tears here in new york
city they can't get they're not going to
get inventory rug inventory until next
year they might not make it through the
holiday season because they can't pay
their rent your thoughts are all done
well i think that uh you're putting way
too much blame on joe biden not that
that is surprising i understand that
he's an easy target but he we've lived
through the most disruptive health
crisis in a century we've lost 700 000
americans it is not surprising that not
just joe biden but the owner and the guy
runs walmart and all the target and all
the other big stores amazon they they
didn't anticipate this phenomenon either
he had all these people getting all this
money his 1400 check wait a second just
said they did anticipate it and that was
months and months ago
well they who's they that they
anticipated oh my goodness
listen if you have a ship and you order
the product in january and it gets there
in march don't order it in march the two
weeks before you need it because you're
trying to save money uh spending money
on inventory i think it's really cruel
let me just give you a personal story
quickly
my
youngest just turned 16. as i did with
all of my children i got her a car i got
her a mini okay and i got her older
sister and the oldest sister they all
got minis
i sat down it was great celebration oh
sol you're 16 you passed your driver's
test isn't this great
the car is gonna be delivered in four
months yeah i mean it's like crazy but
these people you are truly suffering
your brand new car is delayed
oh listen to the listen to the popular
this called witness listen
listen to the populist you know who
lives in his mansion in greenwich
village
my point is that this is a this is a
cascading problem where plenty of people
are responsible and didn't know geraldo
this is the president states he says the
buck stops what if it was trump
everybody knew this was coming months
before and now he has a task force okay
but he had the task force hasn't done
anything they had a commission in
february and they reported in june
the bite administration on on the supply
chain issues and one of the things they
said is you know what we need
more green energy oh it's always green
energy it's always the answer to they
like the high gas prices because it
forces people to use green energy that
doesn't make any economic sense unless
gas is
a at 3.50
pray for that many to come as soon as
possible
thank you